[Music]
whenever skyward sword is being
discussed
the laneru desert is one area of the
game that is brought up quite frequently
it's definitely a fan favorite location
including mine it has some stellar music
interesting and mysterious ruins some of
the best dungeons in the lenero mining
facility and the sand chip and of course
one of the best
gameplay mechanics in any zelda game to
date the time shift stones
the scorching sands of la neru hold all
sorts of tales from a race of sentient
machines their futuristic and highly
sophisticated infrastructure a hidden
and powerful technology
and the tragedy of severe climate change
and today i want to take a closer look
at this fascinating location
discuss some of the ruins the purpose
they once served what made it all fall
into decay over the many centuries
and other little tidbits of information
about this area suffice it to say
spoilers are inbound if you haven't
finished the game yet or at the very
least haven't played through all the
sections of this province
i advise coming back later these parts
of the game are definitely worth going
in blind
it really is that good with that said
let's get into it
[Music]
let's start by getting the lay of the
land some of the first things we learn
about la neru is that it wasn't always a
desert but instead a vast and green
landscape
and that it was once home to a mining
operation and not just
any mining operation but an absolutely
massive one
upon entering la neru for the first time
from the south the mines are one of the
first places we encounter
a network of caves tunnels and quarries
connected by minecarts
it is also here that we learned that the
timeshift stones which we'll get into
later are the primary resource being
mined and transported here
beyond this point we enter what i would
consider the central square of this
operation
in the present it looks like just a
bunch of disconnected pieces of wall
sticking out from
the sand but one quick glance at the map
shows that they used to be connected
sort of like a web of elevated walkways
at the center of all this we find the
entrance to the lenairu mining facility
a sort of pyramid-like structure with a
stairway leading up to it
this entrance is initially buried and
doesn't show up until link activates
three power nodes which all correspond
with the elements of the three dragon
deities
water fire and electricity two of these
power nodes are found inside two
buildings which
according to the game one served as
power generators or power plants
once all power nodes are activated the
mining facility rises from the earth
huh that looks kind of familiar anyway
we also find the temple of time to the
west of the central square of which its
entrance is initially blocked by impa
but is later cleared away by girohim
during his attack on zelda
luckily for link there is a secondary
entrance leading into the temple of time
which requires traversing the leneiro
mining facility whose back entrance
leads directly
into the temple we'll get into more
detail about these structures later when
we cover the overall infrastructure its
purpose and how it's all connected
to the southeast of the central square
there is a cave leading into three
different directions
one of them loops back to the mines the
other two leneru gorge home of the
thunder dragon and the third one leads
to the ancient harbor
aside from being the home of the thunder
dragon the gorge isn't all that
interesting to talk about
there is one additional cave system here
but judging from the mine carts and the
oar shoots this was simply yet another
excavation site and nothing more as for
the dragon spirit his role has been
revealed to be protecting and watching
over the province
as is often the case with deities in the
zelda series
the ancient harbor is where things get a
lot more interesting
it borders what's known in the present
as the sansee
a huge stretch of desert land which
houses three prominent structures
skipper's retreat the shipyard and the
pirate stronghold
additionally a large vessel known as the
sand ship sails around in this area as
well
with all that said it's obvious that
every one of these structures
the mines the mining facility power
generators temple of time
ancient harbor and sancy are all
intrinsically connected
they all played a part in whatever
operation was going on here
which brings us to the ancient robots in
charge of said operation
although they are clearly built by
someone to serve a specific purpose
their ai in terms of complexity seems to
be on par with the consciousness of
non-synthetic life forms they display
feelings of fear
grief anger love excitement and other
emotions commonly seen in biological
creatures
despite this they do seem to be
programmed to serve various purposes
which all contribute to a single end
goal
most of them don't have unique names and
are simply called by their model number
ld-301 which according to phi
are just one of a number of
mass-produced robots there are some
exceptions though
as we meet two similar ancient robots
who do have a name that being skipper
and scrapper they do still have the same
model number as all the others but with
an additional letter
probably to signify their special role
followed by the name
the regular 301 models seem to be part
of the general workforce
those who perform the mining manage the
infrastructure and so on while skipper
and scrapper are more unique models who
serve different purposes
skipper being a captain who commands the
sand chip and its crew
and scrapper likely being a salvager or
transport robot
seeing as he is able to fly and is
outfitted and programmed to carry and
transport heavy objects there might have
been more of the same type of model as
skipper and scrapper but as far as we
know
they are the only survivors of their
kind i like to think that the l in ld
simply stands for la neru as a way to
indicate the location where these robots
would be deployed
at first i thought ld simply stands for
le neru desert but then i realized that
when these robots were made la neru
probably wasn't a desert yet so that
would make no sense
so whatever a la neru droid
digger i am definitely overthinking this
besides in some languages the prefix is
totally different
301 seems to be the number assigned to
the generation it belongs to
which could mean that there were other
models preceding the 301 generation ones
which were discontinued perhaps because
of
errors or glitches in their system or
because the technology simply advanced
further and further over time
and there is actually some proof for
this as there is another ancient robot
with a different model number than the
rest
that being the pirate captain also known
as ld-002g
scurvo just like all the others it has
the ld prefix but its model number is
002
instead of 301 meaning that he's from a
much older generation
likely the second generation this
explains why he looks so vastly
different from the other ancient robots
being more tall and humanoid and still
walking on two legs instead of hovering
like the others do hello
this is dawn from the future so while i
was capturing
footage for this episode which i didn't
do until long after i
already recorded the voiceover i
suddenly noticed that the ancient robots
are not hovering in fact they are riding
i don't know why i thought they were
hovering maybe because they move so
smoothly across the surface i thought
they were hovering like a few
centimeters off the ground or something
but no they totally have
wheels i have no idea how i missed this
the first time playing but
you know i thought i'd just mention it
anyway back to the video
it also explains its hostility it is
implied that he once served on the
skipper until turning on his fellow
automata and resorting to mutiny
it then set up its own base that being
the pirate's stronghold and henceforth
started to terrorize the seas and
messing with the transport vessels it's
also implied that he wasn't alone in
doing this and that there was a whole
band of pirates so
maybe the entire zero zero two
generation was enacting this behavior i
guess even robots can long for a
pirate's life
agreed as such this could be the reason
why this particular model was
discontinued as it is
clearly prone to insubordination which
leads into the next question
who was responsible for building these
ancient robots
well it's never outright explained in
the game but the main consensus has
always linked them to the shika
the only real concrete evidence we had
for this at the time of skyward sword's
original release was the sheikah eye
symbol
present on some of the timeshift stones
as well as the fact that the gates of
time which are clearly hinted have been
built by the shika
are made from time shift stones the main
resource being mined at la neru desert
but that was back in 2011
nowadays with the addition of breath of
the wild and age of calamity the
evidence for the shika being responsible
for the construction of the ancient
machines and their interest in time
shift stones has become much more
convincing
prior to skyward sword the shika were
mostly portrayed as a shadowy ninja
tribe who served the royal family of
hyrule sure there were some small hints
at their connection to time such as the
gossip stones but it was all very much
open to interpretation breath of the
wild was the first to truly showcase
undeniable proof of the tribe's affinity
and skill to build sophisticated
high-tech machinery and the age of
calamity demonstrated its connection to
actual time travel we learned from one
of the 301 models inside the mines that
all ancient machinery which they
themselves are part of are all powered
by time shift stones
it is also what incentivizes them to
keep the operation running as without
new timeshift stones they will
inevitably shut down
this proves that the timeshift stones
although incredibly powerful as an
energy source
are finite and will run out of juice
eventually and it's possible that the
ancient blue energy seen in breath of
the wild is directly linked to time
shift stones in liquid form this time
around
but that's a whole other story however
it's also clear that powering the
technology that drives the mining
operation
is not the end goal after all why mine
something
just to fuel the very system to mine
more like a perpetual cycle
instead it seems there was a much more
significant intention behind all of this
one of which of course being the
construction of the gates of time
but the question is why we know that
they were ultimately used by link and
his friends to travel between the past
and the present in order to defeat
demise
but these mining operations clearly took
place long
long before the time period link and
zelda live in we are never given a
definitive number in terms of how much
time spans between the past when these
mining operations took place
and the present i.e the time period
lincoln zelda grew up in but it is made
clear that it's at least
a few thousand years the main purpose
for the construction of the gates of
time was to find
zelda in the future so she could become
the vessel for goddess hylia as well as
being used by link in his fight against
demise
so how did the chica know to build two
gates to travel through time for
something that wouldn't transpire until
thousands of years into the future and
the obvious answer is
this wasn't their idea instead they were
simply doing what goddess hylia
instructed them to do
it's clear that the goddess perceives
time very differently than regular
mortals
including the chica from her memory phi
sometimes communicates messages
directly from the goddess to link in
which she says that she will guide him
from her place
at the quote-unquote edge of time the
fact that she can construct such an
elaborate plan which is executed over
the course of thousands of years
creating phi in the goddess sword
preparing zelda to be her vessel
and leaving messages for a hero who
won't be born until thousands of years
later
shows that her nature as a divine being
allows her to see time in a very
different construct
knowing what needs to be done long
before it happens she knew that demise
would break free someday and probably
even knew when
as such she ordered the shika to start a
massive mining operation to gather the
timeshift stones needed to construct the
gates of time
which brings us back to the lenairu
desert it is shown to us that the
construction of a time gate requires
huge amounts of crystals and two needed
to be built so you can imagine the
quantity
these crystals also seem to be much more
pure and refined than the raw stones we
find inside the quarries
as such a huge workforce was needed to
meet this quota
numbers which the shika at the time
likely didn't have
and being the friendly neighborhood
ninjas that they are instead of
resorting to
classic slavery they instead build
machines to get the job done
with all that in mind it's quite easy to
piece together how the project operated
which is where we need to take a leap
into the province's ancient past
it is unfortunately never explained what
the origins of the timeshift stones is
or how they came to be so abundant in
this province in particular but it might
have a connection to the goddess of
wisdom
nehru which the province is named after
she is said to be the source of the
fundamental laws that govern the world
which probably includes time as well
we can see this trend return in oracle
of ages where we meet a character by the
same name
nehru who's connected to time but that's
all just speculation and we may never
know so let's focus on the mining
project itself
from the looks of it the raw material
was dug up inside the mini caves
particularly the mines to the south
from there they would be transported to
the mining facility by a series of mine
carts and likely also by 301s series
like scrapper who were capable of
carrying heavy loads from location to
location
one of the ancient robots close to the
entrance to the mining facility states
that it's here that the timeshift stones
were produced so the facility
was nothing more than just a huge
factory in which the raw timeshift
crystals were
processed and refined the power plants
nearby as you may have guessed supplied
power to the factory and it seems that
in the case of an emergency like an
attack from outside forces the power to
the facility could be severed after
which it would sink into the ground
inside the facility we see a further
desire to protect and secure the
operation from possible intruders as phy
states that the bmo's enemies
are in fact not monsters with malicious
intent but simply a part of the ancient
security system that would have
protected the facility
obviously since link is an unregistered
entity from a different time period no
less it recognizes him as an intruder
and
attacks him at the end of the line of
the facility the now refined timeshift
crystals would have been transported to
two different locations
right through the back door and into the
temple of time where the first gate
would be constructed which explains why
there's a back door in the first place
and the rest would be transported to the
ancient harbor this also showcases the
detailed environmental storytelling in
this province
in the boss room which is the second to
last room of the facility we can see
multiple railway tunnels leading
underground
accompanied by these mechanical trains
which would have been able to transport
multiple wagons filled with timeshift
stones
at the ancient harbor we see something
similar multiple railway tunnels
all coming together at one central point
likely the end of the very same tunnels
we saw inside the mining facility so the
harbor is where the remaining crystals
from the facility
accumulated and from here they would be
loaded onto ships and transported across
the sand sea to their final destination
those who've played the game know that
the sansi wasn't always
well a sea of sand and probably didn't
even go by that name
because in the past it was a real sea a
vast body of water stretching across the
west of the province and
into unknown territory skipper's retreat
and the shipyard
speak for themselves places where the
crews of the ships lived and where the
ships were being built and repaired and
of course the pirate fortress which as
mentioned before was likely built by the
older models who went rogue at some
point
but what happened after this where did
the remaining timeshift stones go well
as mentioned before a second gate of
time was being constructed in the farron
province inside the temple of hylia
and if i had to guess this is exactly
where the other crystals were being
transported to
large sections of skyward sword's map
are left blank and we aren't allowed to
see what lies there but if we are to
assume that the sea stretches all the
way across the bottom of the map
just like it does in breath of the wild
then it suddenly becomes clear why the
time shift stones were being loaded onto
ships to the west
instead of directly being transported
east towards the fahren province
transporting big loads across the sea
requires a lot less infrastructure
and is a lot faster than having to haul
small loads across
land one at a time or having to build
roads railways and tunnels
all the way from one province to the
next all you need is a couple of ships
two docks and you're good to go the
ships could carry huge amounts to ferren
unload them at the dock after which they
would only be a stone throws away
from their final destination puns
and in fact we do see that farren is
closely connected to water
there's a huge lake at the bottom which
could be salt water based
and rivers running in and out of the
province so yes i believe the purpose of
the shipping routes was likely to
transport timeshift stones to farren
after which they would be used to
construct the second gate of time
maybe some leftover time crystals were
exported to other locations
perhaps traded or sold to other
provinces or maybe even other continents
but i don't believe that would have been
the main goal
now before we move on to the final
segment where we cover the decline of
leneru there's one more idea i want to
discuss
and i'm curious what you guys think now
that i've actually played the game
myself
there's one section in the game which
immediately left me with a lot of
questions
which is this part right before the
second fight with girohim
up until this point in the story the
existence of the second gate of time was
unknown not only to girahim but link as
well it is here that they first find
out because of an ancient decoration on
a wall but this wall is inside the fire
sanctuary all the way up in the elden
province what is this ancient drawing
doing here
i never got the impression that the
ancient chica were active in elden
there's no
time shift stones or ancient machinery
to be found here nor does the shikai
symbol make an appearance
this section of elden volcano is also
extremely inhospitable
it is apparent that there was an ancient
civilization living here but if anything
i would have expected this to be a race
like the gorons or maybe the magma
you know creatures who are known to be
able to resist extreme temperatures
and if this is true then why would the
ancient shika share this secret
information about the two gates of time
with some
unknown group of people living in elden
you would think that the less people
know about this stuff
the bigger the chance of you know
keeping it a secret
then i realized that most of the
materials used to construct the robots
the railways the other machinery
consists of some sort of metal right
but as far as we know there's no metal
present in la neru or farren for that
matter
but you know who does have metal the
elden province
more specifically elden orr according to
the lore found inside the fire sanctuary
the eldon province was once ruled by an
unknown king
is it a coincidence then that inside the
fire sanctuary which
looks like an ancient palace we find
this depiction of the two gates of time
the only depictions of them in hyrule
this means that whoever the king and the
people who lived here were they were
likely the only ones who knew about the
gates of time
aside from the shrika maybe in exchange
for eldon or the sheikah let them in on
the secret or
promised other things in return or the
king was just a good samaritan who
wanted to help with hailey's plan
either way there was definitely a deeper
connection between the chica and this
ancient kingdom which i don't know i
just found very interesting
maybe i'll do a more detailed video
about this ancient kingdom since there
are a lot of mysteries to uncover but
for now i'll just leave it as it is
and with that we arrive at the final
subject the decline
or should i say desertification of la
neru it's not exactly a mystery as to
why lenairu fell into decay and slowly
turned into a desert
i mean it's flat out told to us in the
game and for a change it didn't have
anything to do with evil doers
curses or wars but simply a case of
severe climate change as a result of too
much industry the land was
literally being depleted and it seems
that the robots themselves were not
oblivious to the change in their
environment
since inside one of the power stations
we find a notice which mentions the
decline of the area
stating that plants are dying and even a
call to action to keep la neru green
it's not exactly clear if it was the
machines who set into motion the slow
decay of plant life in the region
some speculate that the timeshift stones
themselves may have had sort of a
radioactive element to them
after all one of the robot states that
the crystals are quote
dangerous to humans but it never
explains why or what that means
whatever the case may be it's obvious
that the mining project had something to
do with the rapid change in la neru's
landscape and also that there was very
little that could be done to stop it
once the problem was noticed
planting new trees clearly didn't help
the soil had lost its fertility and
slowly but surely the issues of climate
change became bigger and bigger
as more and more plants and trees died
the province became
increasingly dry sand started clogging
up the machines and facilities slowly
grinding the mechanisms to mine and
refine timeshift stones to a halt
without new supplies of time shift
stones the machines started shutting
down as there was no longer any power to
support them
until finally the entire synthetic
workforce of la neru succumbed to the
loss of energy by the time
link visits the province the mining
operations have laid dormant for a very
long time
how long exactly is unknown but it has
to be at least a thousand years
this is given away by the presence of
the araka scorpion-like creatures who've
made a home for themselves
inside the province they aren't found in
the past indicating that they only
started migrating to leneru due to the
changing climate
according to phi if they live long
enough to survive their very lengthy
larval state
they grow up to be a moldorak a gigantic
scorpion which bears the nickname
thousand-year arachnid we can find two
of these in the game
one inside the mining facility and the
other inside the shipyard's construction
bay
the very existence of these
thousand-year arachnid shows that
these factories have been abandoned for
at least a thousand years
and likely longer than that since then
la neru has sort of become like a ghost
town with its only inhabitants being the
various creatures who managed to survive
the harsh climate and the occasional
treasure hunter or adventure brave
enough to explore the area
it's a great example of a land that once
was the remains of its glory day slowly
but surely being wiped from history by
nature
buried beneath a layer of dust and sand
it's a bit of a sad sight to behold
although the ancient robots were mere
machines so to speak
they show clear signs of having led
normal lives things like
friendship family and companionship but
alas
now they laid a waste in the scorching
sun unable to speak
i guess even the life of a robot has to
come to an end sometime
although we don't know much about what
happened after the events of skyward
sword
it's highly likely that la neru was the
precursor to the gerudo desert home of
the gerudo and the future king of evil
ganondorf
inside the province a small flying
creature can be found which carries the
name
the gerudo dragonfly which is long
before the gerudo even saw their
inception and it might just be that this
little creature is what ultimately
served as the inspiration for the name
of the future tribe that would come to
live here
[Music]
you